well Jonah by Chris horseman he's in the
EU agricultural policy and trade
consultant um Victoria Houston she's
senior counsel for the Gotham Institute
special trade commission that's a
london-based
think-tank Victoria stop we did this is
great news isn't it and then to EU
quotas in this particular product well
any liberalizing measure is to be
welcomed of course ultimately the aim of
a trade policy shouldn't be it isn't
always the case but it should be to
maximize the choice and quality
available to consumers so by taking away
quotas that's a step in the right
direction unfortunately in this case
it's a very partial measure and
ultimately doesn't really meet that
requirement of improving choice and
value for consumers because you still
don't have the option to buy cane sugar
with without being controlled really by
the tariffs and quotas that the EU has
imposed well British sugar would would
argue that actually that protecting
domestic sugar production against highly
subsidized cane sugar production from
places like Brazil and Thailand well
yeah and that's always a risk of course
is that the playing field isn't quite
level but there are better ways of
leveling the playing field and
countering those distortions from highly
subsidized markets than by the blunt
instrument of sticking a crater on it so
limiting the the amount of imports and
also tariffs see you increase the the
price of those inputs there are better
more sophistical more sophisticated ways
of doing that that are more liberalizing
and improve consumer welfare by way of
choice and price which would be
presumably bringing down terrace more
generally across the board yeah
absolutely bring bring down tariffs and
utilize better ways of countering
distortions by examining what the effect
of subsidies in those markets are and if
they're truly distorting and
unreasonable then you can look at
deploying measures to to impose tariffs
there let's bring Chris in at this point
on Chris this is the problem with a lot
of what the EU has done the Common
Agricultural Policy over there it's
artificially kept food prices high
yes it has and sugar has been
particularly badly distorted over the
years the the sugar quota a system which
has been in place for 49 years which is
now finally disappearing has has kept a
lid on supply and as they're
artificially kept prices up but nothing
in in the sugar trade situation is ever
straightforward and you know you've
you've got the situation where there are
very heavy tariffs applied on on imports
of sugar from from some countries but
not from others because the likes of
Tate & Lyle can import sugar from
developing countries Commonwealth
countries completely free of tariffs the
problem is that countries like Brazil
and Thailand to produce sugar more
efficiently and much cheaper and that's
really what UK refiners would like to
get their hands on there's a trade-off
though isn't that because ultimately you
do want our limits of protection for
British farmers or do well yeah I mean
this is where the sort of the
post-colonial politics of sugar trading
bumps up against the the politics of
brexit the there is I think in the UK a
lot of sentiment towards you know being
able to to to have access to free trade
but the prop the problem in this case is
that free trade will actually mean
disadvantaging the British producer
which which goes against the usual kind
of Brit Pro brexit narrative if we if we
can put it that way so basically the UK
government has got a very difficult
decision to make whether it increases
access to imported cane sugar or whether
it continues to support domestic beet
production and it basically has to
decide after brexit which are those two
parties it disappoints gone for talk I
think the the issue there of course is
by protecting British beet sugar
producers you're effectively protecting
one monopoly supplier
and suppressing more innovative
suppliers who might be able to make
better use of global supply chains like
for example taking live wood would argue
about they do I think the days of
controlling the products available on a
market in order to protect domestic
invested interests should be long behind
us I think we've seen with the reaction
to for example uber having its license
suspended
consumers really do start to value the
choice and the innovations available to
them and we should be applying the same
principles to our agricultural market
very briefly isn't there a case for
saying farmers do an awful lot more I
mean they they look after the
environment they preserve the British
countryside you're putting all that at
risk if you allow the country to be
exposed to ranching and we certainly
wouldn't argue for just pulling the rug
away from farmers in a you know
uncontrolled way though there is still a
cases to be made for making direct
payments to farmers but moving away from
the more distortive land-based payments
that will prey under the cap very
briefly Chris last word to you isn't
there a case for saying that we should
really tear down some of these EU quotas
on the basis that we're hurting
developing countries we're preventing
them from making a living in the global
markets yes I mean there is there's a
very strong case that needs to be made
there and what the British government
has to decide is whether it's possible
to reallocate the subsidies that are
currently paid under the under the
common agricultural policy after brexit
it's got an opportunity to reformulate
agricultural policy in such a way that
the environment is protected that food
standards are protected but that there
isn't necessarily the same amount of
money just going into giving farmers
area payments because they've got the
land it's already in Chris Halsman
thanks both